all right so-called experts failed
far-left governors continue to impose
draconian lockdowns restrictions
on americans all across the country
earlier today our own lawrence
jones was asking new yorkers about the
cdc's new guidelines for thanksgiving
and travel
and left-wing hypocrisy lj why
what are the people saying
good evening sean as you know the cdc is
recommending that
all americans not travel or gather in
groups unless they can properly
social distance but the question is do
these rules apply to those that make the
rules
earlier today i had the opportunity to
talk with new yorkers this is what they
had to say
watch so the cdc is recommending people
don't travel
or get together for thanksgiving is that
going too far is that the right thing
no it's the right move it's necessary
unfortunately
i think you've got the cdc who certainly
has their obligation to take care of the
american public
they've made a recommendation that
people not travel it's probably a wise
thing to do
because they're looking at trying to
keep the country safe well i think it
varies
it's really difficult to tell people
what to do and put
restrictions on them because people are
human people need to be with their
families
people yearn for human contact
especially around the holidays we
believe that we're
also cheating when you have these
governors and mayors telling us
put on a mask telling us to socially
distant
and then you look at them they're not
wearing a mask sometimes
you are correct they're gathering with
their family that's where they've kept
this country ignorant
because they were preaching one thing
and doing another i think shame on them
you know we
we look to our political leaders to not
only keep us safe but to provide
the right examples for us to follow and
when they have an inability to comply
with
simple things like wearing a mask i
think it sets a bad example and it
certainly hasn't done
anything to keep our country safer
now sean i did get the opportunity to
talk with some folks that planned
on traveling they didn't want to be on
camera because they did not want to be
targeted
or fired from their jobs so they just
decided to give
me their comments off the record back to
you sean
lawrence you're welcome to my house
anytime you want anytime
love to have you you can come by violate
the rules of new york some of that
turkey
listen i fry my turkey all right thank
you my friend all right